but you can Susannah chillin on da cunha
pura vida no proof web I do a lot of
stuff gallstone go I climb trees I can
somersault I can dance this wreck downs
Uganda's youngest female rapper is 14
and goes by the name of MC Lloyd she's
become a star in her country regularly
wrapping the news on Uganda's and TV the
weekly voice recording in a production
company is followed by a TV studio
session this modern news format is
designed to reach young people who don't
normally watch the news despite France
under the bill might have the economy
and sent back to Ibaka famous back to
Parvati making them to get to know
what's happening in the country abroad
and so on that really helps that helps
them like to know what's going on in the
world cause if you live in the world and
you know nothing about what's happening
then you may find yourself in a bad
thing or problem or songs that often
happens to people in her generation half
the population is under 15 Facebook and
whatsapp predominate here young people
would rather listen to music then to the
news so what better way is there to
reach them than to bring the message
across with music Zoe kablooey that's
her real name buys newspapers as often
as she can what bothers her is that not
everyone can go to school in Uganda
that's part of child abuse non-technical
child that's cool I wouldn't blame like
parents who don't have money to take
children at school but I would only
blame the government which like doesn't
use that infrastructure for like for the
kids at home schools yeah her desire to
remove fear and instill courage
motivates her to teach kids at Sunday
school
you will hold a son in your arms well he
has no son and husband is old no no
education for all no more corruption she
is even put her demands to the president
wrapping them of course yes I'm proud to
be a ugandan living in the beautiful
model and a pal of Africa that grows
every day an egg with mega malls roads
hospitals education system and so much
more but we need some more and I want to
be the first no president of my country
Uganda the pearl of Africa what yeah the
closet oh yeah you know I met him know
that I want to be so he should just get
prepared for MC loi open his seat
someday according to the constitution
she has to wait until she's 35 to run
for president leaving her plenty of time
to get the word out to all her fans